that's a tough tough life to be a pen
now let it roast you tough life to be a
pig now you saw Papa shops grilling
skills when I was cooking them them them
rib eyes yeah I did my favorite things
is grill Rama I'm a rib eye kicks told
me a piece too the hardest thing I took
it off to see if it was done and you ate
it
yeah which is usually frowned upon
around the grill where I'm from Yeah
right
penalty is usually death and why is that
what I do I'm trying to figure out let
it cool off and by the time I look down
you eat it oh so you want us out you
were high well we must [ __ ] we have
talking do drogas podcasts he sorts come
over my house for dinner right I'm like
dude you haven't seen the new crib right
I'm close to Rogen I know dude you got
to come over
he was cool man and I SEMATECH sir hey
give me a heads up cuz I'm grilling
these organic rib eyes blah blah blah
hyping him up I get tech from that goes
dude the spelling was way off to is like
all [ __ ] up goes dude so high I said
oh my go at one point I go I really need
you to come and get me like I need help
sometimes you have to ask your friend
for helman sweats so chilling now I
didn't know that so I I go to his house
he picks me up now your crib there's
something very special about it because
it's big but it's how I was so jealous I
was there I was high but what you were
oh the first friend I met the person
that sobered me out was that little boy
he wanted to show you his room oh my
Chatty Cathy is built like a Navy SEAL
yeah he's ready for buds now I told Brad
I said once you come over and get five
seating my son he's looking for grappler
all his hands are about the size of mine
he's three years old he's got traps he's
he's built like Tito Ortiz I'm not
actually after I was after I came back
to Joe's studio after you picked me up
and dropped me off still wasn't okay to
drive still wasn't okay to drive so you
test the drive itself no I'm not like
that so I had to work out I had to work
out what yeah well she's do you have a
problem with her
the may sound disaster and in France we
say see own disaster powerful dad box
yeah you were high as [ __ ] though man I
took one hit I don't smoke weed you kept
going Wow and where are we I was like
dude we're come on dude I was - yeah I
don't remember a lot of it Joanna wait
he's not gonna come over and be all
weird is you know what no you probably
I'm gonna tell I will I'm trying not
Tigers definitely I gonna tell I was
trying not to be weird but I knew you're
high when you grab that [ __ ] hot meat
off the shelf man because I jumped in an
uber oh you dig in uber huh yeah I think
I could grab Danny went to dinner that
night yeah I was still I just couldn't
drive hi I don't I don't take that
chance so I had to wait and I rode
Rogen's bike I lifted weights I thought
we had we do not get it's not like it
doesn't go away no you're not gonna work
it sweat it out I'm not know Jesus it
was it was three hours Derek and a sauna
night that you know fans always bring me
weed even though I am really not a pot
guy but there was bringing weed well
Derek and Hassan or both we do they
smoke like every night so they had this
fat joint and we stayed in a haunted
hotel a very haunted hotel and the first
I slept with one while on I was a cow
not big not a big deal slept with light
on then I was like oh I don't have to
leave till noon tomorrow I'm smoke a
little weed with these guys
smoked a big old fat doobie bad idea I
was so paranoid in my room I got zero
sleep zero sleep had to sleep with TV
loudest [ __ ] all the lights on I was so
scared man I was just when you get high
and get paranoid
yeah I don't think about ghosts and I'm
like maybe I should just look up what
these guys saw didn't you read these all
this [ __ ] about what NBA plate cuz all
NBA the Cavs were there when we were
there all the MLB steams stay there so
when you looked up what those guys were
reporting when I start getting super
paranoid do you smoke weed every night
no never
I can't remember last time smoke weed
yeah I take CBD oil genet
which is non psychoactive no THC zero
you rarely I meet you I never saw my THC
my system was probably I don't even know
last time was when we were on Rogan it
was you me and Eddie and I was drinking
yeah I got so [ __ ] up deaf
shoulda drove home that's right GFI
should not draw like follow eight
minutes but it's not eight minutes I
Drive a tank but definitely should have
drove oh yeah yeah but I also I don't
like smoking because I I'm a control
freak so I don't like feeling out of
controls how I feel and then I'll so I
have some [ __ ] inside me that I want to
say yeah but I feel term I self yes well
I but I feel like when I smoke weed I'm
just gonna blur it all out I'm gonna win
my when I do a book I'm gonna put it in
there but I want to waste on pockets I'm
high well at one point I was talking to
Joe we were having a great conversation
and the weed hit and he started to he
started to disappear into a tunnel why
are you in a tunnel and why can't why do
I have no peripheral vision and why are
you echoing why does your voice sound
echoing that's how high are you super
well it's also like it's not like Joe
has that normal we'd then have that
normal push isn't what does he have is
how long he's been doing [ __ ] the
mary-jane so he's not gonna have your
normal run-of-the-mill high school [ __ ]
race is that psychoactive joe rogan
let's take a hit on like attitude I mean
they're just gonna get super quiet
because I get self-conscious I'm gonna
rattle off some weird [ __ ] or I'll never
do it again cuz I got a drive so can't
do it I live so close I get a little
high with the fight campaign this is fun
I think there's sort of fight Sunday is
the fight Sunday Saturday I think in a
while there's another Sunday Sunday's
are the best days it's not there's a
great we got to do a Sunday so much fun
yeah man it's it was it was fun but I
think it I think it will shot a whiskey
now before I go on stage one shot of
whiskey one beer that's my new thing
I I kept looking in your fridge you
don't know this because you were putting
Tiger to bed and I kept going to your
fridge opening it and then closing it I
remember doing that going back to the
times did you grab anything didn't grab
a thing well I was like is there any
cheese in here I got a drinks for days
lot of liquid a lot of liquid in there
that you as it's a Gish it's a gift it's
a gift